[Applause]
thank you so much welcome back
this hour we are celebrating the
extraordinary nurses who care for us
during the toughest of times and our
next guest is no exception she is a
nurse innovator and advocate for her
fellow nurses addressing health
disparities for underserved people and
she is truly amazing so let's take a
peek at andrea's story
[Music]
hi my name is andrea caramillo and i am
a hospice nurse a clinical research
nurse a consultant for a wellness
startup and a nurse farmer
i was born in ecuador and grew up never
knowing a single nurse i moved to the
u.s when i was 16 and became an
interpreter for the national institute
of health it was there where i saw the
strength and power of nurses in a
patient's life and i knew that i wanted
to care for people in the same way
working with underserved communities is
very important for me because i was one
of the patients who did not have access
to care at one point
so giving back to the community it's
very rewarding for me
nurses are the cornerstone of every
healthcare system and immigrants are the
backbone of american society i think of
nurses as activists advocates but most
importantly as catalysts for change
that's why i always felt compelled to
bring my own chair to the table
after years of being a registered nurse
i realized how quickly nurses could burn
out which was exacerbated even more with
the onset of covet
nurses are natural problem solvers and
because we spend so much time caring for
patients directly we're always seeing
ways to improve our systems of care but
we get frustrated because for many
nurses there is no clear way to raise
and implement these amazing ideas and we
want to be a part of the solution that
is why i became involved in the society
of nurse scientists innovators
entrepreneurs and leaders or sun ciel
for sure
there we provide a community for nurses
with innovative ideas to come together
and support each other we want to
empower nurses to make an impact as the
innovators and pioneers that we are
sun ciel has given me permission to
define what nursing means to me and
allow me to rediscover my love for
caring for others without losing myself
i want to continue to help nurses
discover the same thing
please everybody give a warm welcome to
nurse andrea
thank you i am so excited to celebrate
you thank you okay so you worked very
hard to become a nurse is this correct
this is correct it took me about 10
years uh you know i applied to almost
all the schools in the new england area
i had seven rejections and eventually i
got into this really great university
umass boston where i graduated in 2017
with honors
[Applause]
how wonderful when you can show them see
you accepted me and look what i did
and son ciel was started in 2019 but
you and your team have already been to
the united nations
we did
we got a team of nurses a group and we
showed up
to learn how we can be part of these
committees where decisions are being
made
nurses we are experts we need to bring
our expertise to the table we need to
bring our voices and i think
there is 28 million nurses roughly
around the world and we are
underrepresented where decisions are
being made so i think
this is the main thing we want to bring
we want to bring our chair and sit at
those tables because if we're not you
know at the table we're on the menu and
i think it's important
[Applause]
well because we are teaming up with
johnson and johnson to honor nurses i
wanted to invite a friend
a new friend of mine um to join us
please welcome johnson and johnson
executive vice president michael snead
[Applause]
is fantastic wow this is fantastic so
much of what you've done has made this
possible really and truly we're indebted
to you with gratitude that is honestly
not able to be put into words and
what i'd like to ask you is you know
you've decided to make it a company
mission and a priority to advocate for
support and to empower nurses
why did that come about what is it that
spoke to you and what did you say this
is what we need to do yeah well look
it's johnson johnson is certainly a
priority for us when it comes to nursing
but drew it's also a personal priority
for me
over the last several months i've
actually traveled the country
talking to nurses in communities and
really hearing their stories and and
it's been tough you know the nurses
around the us have been dealing with a
pandemic
they've been trying to work to close the
health gap in their communities
and oftentimes they're feeling you know
burned out they're feeling
neglected as andrea talked about
but at the same time i've heard some
great stories that have been so
uplifting you know when i see these
nurses and i hear their stories what i
can tell you about nurses
is that they are problem solvers
i can i can tell you that they are
advocates for their patients i can tell
you that they're innovators i can tell
you that they're leaders in the
community nurses are the backbone of the
healthcare system and so when we lift
them up it's better for us it's better
for all of us and certainly better for
our health and it's one of the reasons
why johnson johnson has been such a
supporter of nurses for the last 125
years
and it's because we see their ability to
really be advocates to
be
have the ability to empower themselves
and each other to be able to educate
people and when you think about
superheroes that's what superheroes do
and so that's what all these nurses do
every single day
now um
i think um you might have a little
surprise for andrea is this correct as
you know you talked about her
organization son seal yes which is a
tremendous organization by the way doing
amazing things but the great thing about
it is this sun seal is an organization
that empowers so many other nurses when
it comes to
what they do in terms of being a nurse
scientist and all the things that
they do so on behalf of johnson and
johnson we want to present to you a
grant of 25 000
to help you
continue the work that you do
[Applause]
i'd love to get in on this i'm also
gonna do a little something for you
because again all i have to offer all i
make are
um things uh that you know i want to
improve life with and spark joy um so i
would also like to send you with all the
beautiful
appliances the flower hair tools and the
flower beauty as a woman-to-woman gift
it's amazing thank you through well
thank you andrea hotter
and thank you to the executive vice
president of johnson and johnson michael
smeed
what you do for the world is incredible
and thank you for being a part of this
show and this hour we will be right back
thank you so much
[Music]